[Applause]
[Music]
awkward things online Oh what someone
didn't act in the normal way ah I hating
I discovered this subreddit after
googling PewDiePie subreddit and this
came up nobody is born cool except yeah
what am I even looking at it's just
confusing I'm sure there's a joke here
somewhere
PewDiePie submission is getting so bad
it's getting so bad guys ok
I'm fighting crunch would cringe hair
even though I admit this is pretty
cringe everyone saying on subreddit that
a subreddit is getting bad it's pretty
cringe and overdone ok we get it
it's getting so bad now I can't walk in
my hat doing some ok no one cares
it's like throughout my entire youtube
career I've been hearing PT buddies
getting so bad now steady decline for 12
years that's how we do it alright but
that was putting that aside that little
monologue let's review some frickin epic
cringe man we all like it let's get real
here
calling Kobe Bryant at 3m oh my god he
actually answered he's not oh my god
could you come up with any more of a
knowing title scum of the earth
it's people like these that makes you
sign that you're a youtuber hey what do
you do youtuber oh you're one of those
huh yeah I'm so sorry
I apologize yep looks about what was
expected
stephen pruitt has made nearly 3 million
edits on wikipedia yep he is balding and
overweight all for free
the street is horrible this man is
literally providing the world with free
knowledge and you think criticizing his
appearance is funny fu yeah Jennifer you
look like a Jennifer Gotham
I want to star in the Netflix series
[Music]
[Laughter]
starring at play exert the Queen
supposed to do do it yourself what is
this hair this hair super cringe what is
happening oh that's great I love that
rare guys I want to be the pie season
scare PewDiePie season 2 I want it out
so bad YouTube
do your thing that is actually correct
nice I've seen this found this at the
bottom of my delivery receipt
thank you to whoever this was pretty
sure this is the vine guy that just
awesome impressions I swear the delivery
instructions are put by whoever orders
though they are this is so embarrassing
he must have put it as a joke right it
could have just been a joke like oh my
god
can't believe right huh cringe you
didn't understand a joke
cringe I cringe that your cringe how
about thank ya I'm above you you're down
here you're nothing you scum scum this
is the worst Christmas hall I've ever
had no pop vinyls no video games no
Google Play PSN or Nintendo network
cards no DVDs table race and as the lego
sets I get for Christmas go this one is
below average I knew that my family
would blow it dick yeah I'll take the
Lego you want to give it to me I'm 30
years old up with Lego I don't give up
you're grateful piece of [ __ ] I'm
cringing I'm just upset a man gotta
appreciate his leg goes Muppet no
garland post 58 off votes garland post
37,000 of votes Wow
that's it artist that sounds like a
funny YouTube video where if you're an
artist post on Reddit and then go in
fiber and ask a girl or someone to hold
up your art and see if there's any
difference I really will clearly we know
it it's just funny how that works
oh my god I'm gonna click upload on this
I hope she
seeds this may be girlfriend she could
be mine oh my god a girl drew guy
digital epic art shouldn't matter who is
behind it okay an episode of Golden
Girls was pulled from Hulu for a
featuring blackfish this was not
blackface this is a mud mask also black
people didn't ask for any of this they
just want police reform you think black
people are going like yeah Thank You
Hulu
thank you so much I mean I'm gonna put
words into people Wow but it's like this
is really what they're after my god
people are calling it out showers are
sexy take up today notice that anime
convention due to attendees body or
their oh my god dude yeah this this
blows my mind you never realize how few
people shower and wanting to go to a
convention I remember pax there's a lot
of smells going on there's a lot of
smells just take a goddamn shower at
least if you're going out in public my
god be a decent human being at least
thank you confirmed
men who objectify women are epping
hashtag real turn he's 18
they're bulges equality lets sexualize
everyone what this is a full grown
balding ass man wearing a backpack can
you believe the audacity of a full grown
bowling ass man wear a backpack oh
that's so cringe the only thing here
that is cringe is you Christine I know I
always try to claw back and seem
unaffected by fad comments but being
criticized harassed judged online for my
weight every single day is genuinely the
worst thing I've ever gone through and I
always let it ruin my entire life well
maybe you shouldn't do it to other
people Christine have you thought of
that treat other people the way you want
to be treated Christine have you thought
of that that's pretty crazy but it also
makes perfect sense my theory has always
been that the people that write really
hateful and
stupid comments it's not a normal thing
to do right
mmm-hmm you have to be something wrong
with yourself to be that kind of person
I always see it as projecting so it's
hard for me to take it seriously when
people write like to be play is look
like dumb face there must be something
wrong with you
hmm pizza pies hair look like my grass
there must be something wrong with you
then beef eyes hair look like Tintin
they're correct answer is P deep eyes
hair looks mother flippin epic how I get
that style I look like the Chad meme
homeless I think I can pull off the Chad
hair I think I got the chin for it
sighs edit the chin to make me look like
Chad me hell yeah mother you Derek Rin
[ __ ] to me mortal Oh Carly be having a
mental meltdown because she has no don't
cry in that cereal they're gonna get
shock stuff up there guys hang in there
during quarantine just remember that
other people like hard the B has it so
much worse what's that your local small
business couldn't support itself during
quarantine well card the B has to eat
soggy cereal so like that sink in
goddamn it that is such a great photo
forgot the flash was on you shouldn't
have taken a picture to begin with you
cringe she has punch oh I saw this
person in real life I have to take photo
of them like they're a person at a zoo
like they're at an animal at the zoo
click click oh god I look stupid now
it's so cringy cuz like she would have
seen him even without the flash it's
always so goddamn obvious when people
point a camera like I see you so cringe
and then they come up after I've said
this before and they're like can I have
photo time you got your photo now get
the [ __ ] outta my sight
that's what I say and then I spit at
them I'm not gonna do it again but just
imagine it do they call you Kylie
billionaire Jenner Kylie Jenner says her
sister teased her for being a
billionaire and it's so relatable it is
so freaking relatable didn't it come out
that she had changed her papers or
something just to make it seem I mean
was so obviously she's not a billionaire
anyway you don't have to yeah it was
revoked she exaggerated her company's
success for years what I'm so shocked
the day my husband asked me to pay Habs
on rent is a day I pack my bags and go
where if you can't even afford half
ready so far not that much cringe I
think my hair has been the worst part I
think I need a shower one of those
showers think I need to do one of those
washings ever heard of those this
Christmas give your wife something she
really wants a cheap pass I've seen this
before
with a clown world we live in a clown
world what is happening I feel like
they're just writing stuff to piss
people off I see so many headlines like
this this is right like alright what
dumb [ __ ] can we put out we're so
desperate we haven't we can't write
anything of substance let's just write
some dumb so people click on it and get
upset alright that's how we do our
business now this man out here wearing a
hentai sweatshirt in the Vatican City
God that hentai shirt feels like the
epitome of my mom has been dressing me
my entire life so now I'm gonna go
online and buy something epic yeah this
is cool right
I understand what's cool on my 10th
birthday my grandma gave me Bible on my
20 birthday I gave it back to her took
me 10 years to cut it in half with his
piece-of-shit sword god damn neckbeards
ruining katanas okay they used to be
cool goddamnit I understand and I
sympathize you want to feel good just
don't post about it online
you may call us katana owners look bad
alright
god damn it watch it done that is a
piece of art that is glorious well done
no cringe your buyer has army in it
cringe yeah I mean the real army oh my
god
Father's Day is such a joke can we just
cancel this day or make it a second
mother say last time I checked mom did
both rows last time I checked my dad did
both roles so shut the [ __ ] up and sit
down
he obviously failed if you talking to a
girl like that [ __ ] there's always one
there's always someone like this I hope
she sees this bro I'm sure she's gonna
see it and show her [ __ ] bro cringe as
we broke up videos way about God I know
there's just a shock because online it
looked like everything was perfect like
and subscribe
there that was epic grown-ass men that
never crowed up look at the color it go
vroom broom and I did the dance so epic
it's weird though cuz I'm glad people
like this exist because then I can feel
anyone can watch this and feel like well
at least I'm not that piece of [ __ ] you
know what I mean it doesn't that feel
good at least Elin trying desperately to
appeal to his diehard reddit demographic
minecraft has amazing legs and
everything they can get a good
multiplayer minecraft working on Tesla's
or maybe create a game that interacted
virtually with reality like pokemon gold
while driving safely I mean it sounds
fun to me I don't see the issue with
this I'm a bit of an Elon shield though
so maybe don't take my word for it but
I'm down it sounds fun you hate fun so
much but you don't play with Lego do you
cringe
I want anime companies and hygiene
product companies to start working
together more my theory is that if we
put Miku on body wash and shampoo then
we both start showering I mean you're
not wrong I don't care with that started
to regret almost everything about my
senior yearbook page code from Bill
Cosby and he looks up to Jared the
subway oh we got a poky tweet we got a
poky tweet you like my hair gee thanks
just brought it ok ok ok with this is
how much was it I want to donate the
exact amount so I feel like I bought it
for you pokey could have a whole
subreddit from I'm just from her fans
beautiful thank you Elin musk is that
I'm not like the other girls of
billionaire 69 days after 4/20 again
haha like what would you rather have
another gray-haired balding overweight
70 year old billionaire but you guys
hate fun that much he's trying to be
like us but he's totally failing ok
I cringe at your cringe ok I will always
defend Elin
if I were white and not white Smith's
silly son I would be the most respected
philosopher of our and all time the [ __ ]
are you saying dude how is Jaden Smith
nice look I dress like girl I am
philosopher now God who said girls with
depression can't wear tube tops
who said girl to depression can't make
duck face literally no one has ever said
that
come on Netflix do your thing get me on
the Netflix show twit there they finally
did it they figured out how to wear
depression as an accessory to get likes
on Instagram very nice I freaked up god
stop going through security at the
airport they had to take my cards out of
the bag needless to say girlfriend is
not happy after finding out I bought
yugioh cards to our no yugioh holiday I
brought you okay
god damn the note that no you Gil
holiday is ruined I can't help myself I
need to bring the yo-yo cards god dammit
you're only you Gil Naoto god dammit
there's nothing left there's nothing
left to enjoy what in that everliving
gazai that's a turd man's got a turd a
respectable sizeable turd on your head
dude excuse me sir
is that a turd you got a turd on your
head dude don't do that oh my god it's
just oh yeah that is this painful cringe
I just realize there's two different
categories
there's joyful cringe middle cringe
and just pain just painful cringe now I
know all the emotions of courage I have
ascended
[Music]
you feel that you feel that one on that
one you felt that too if you ever feel
like a piece of minute just remember
competitive vaping exists yeah look at
these pieces of sheet absolute scum yeah
you guys don't understand cringe do I
have to explain this to the cringe sub
ready if you're not hurting anyone fine
okay but it's like the people that stop
the cars in traffic you're just annoying
you're disrupting everyday people I
don't know if you want to hire out an
arena and do this I don't care
animals burn in Australia animals burn
on a grill hypocrites okay someone said
it yeah I know you're kidding but
similar things happen at a much faster
rate in industrial farms and that is a
serious issue people don't seem to care
about theirs yet make donations to
rescue the animals in Australia which
don't get me wrong that's fantastic but
it's hypocritical to then dismiss all
the suffering which is arguably worse
and factually much bigger that goes in
that burger you just munched I actually
thought I thought about this the other
day was my thought my very interesting
thought okay yeah it was something about
canceled and how people are so upset
over injustice online or what seems like
injustice of people doing bad things so
they cancel them and that's always
happening oh this person did this you're
done but no and I think most people
don't like to see animals in pain but if
you look at it inside a lot of
industries where the how they treat
animal behind-the-scenes inside these
farms or inside the or the way they're
killed it's uncomfortable people would
like it I guarantee you you wouldn't
like it at least in the in the mass
killing and mass production at least not
talking about local farms my point here
I think people don't care so much about
the animals even though if you get upset
about the killing of animals then that
also means that you are partaking in it
which in a way makes you bad when
canceled culture is all about calling
out other people bad so I can feel good
but you can't really do that when you
look at animal issues and how they're
treated cuz it's like what you you have
to at least be a vegan or vegetarian to
do that which is why there are
so knowing okay okay I got it I got the
perfect example okay let's put it this
way if everyone was vegan and vegetarian
and then they saw how animals were
treated then for sure people would be
like I can't believe they're doing this
it's awful
and considering how often people get
called out on it online it it's weird
how that it's never it doesn't get any
traction oh it's me it's me guys God
creating vegans oh just a little bit of
logic up too much I'm not being by the
way too much logic guys just hurts
listen all I'm saying is there's a weird
gap right now with people on the
internet getting very upset about how
animals are mistreated and ignoring a
lot of [ __ ] that's happening in in the
reality of the meat industry that's all
I'm saying
all right eat whatever you want I don't
give a [ __ ] I never seen this come on
it's a trebuchet ain't nothing crunch
here 555 fans are so creepy yeah it was
a reference to the video okay I will of
your cringe oh here it is the classic
don't be racist speaks English dating an
Italian girl and a hex black thank you
don't just don't be racist guys I've
been telling you for so long
classic fun days and purified submission
I wish the summative was less like this
stop you have been blessed by holy
chaotic you may now continue brash or at
least a couple of thousand I don't
really see the point I feel like I meet
people in real life it's like sometimes
I meet fans that are like that they're
like like like like crunchy references
vetted yeah I can't I can't be mad at it
all that was so cringe bro the way you
said Chung Gerson Keanu Reeves we're all
just trying to navigate the internet not
everyone does it perfectly ain't nothing
wrong with that and that's the takeaway
of this video I think yeah yeah that's
it alright guys hope you enjoyed give it
a like
if you smash like you would be blessed
by a big chunk Asst + Keanu Reeves epic
see you next time hey tall it's time to
race what was once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and pull
troops awaits
hope T is coming to Nintendo's wait and
remember it has a very big TV pre-order
promotion heavy
yeah gave me a set book birthday girl I
ran away
[Music]